ready and in every movie Michael is
always looking for a challenge
he really has mastered the new 3d and
IMAX technology on a big scale movie you
want to shoot with a big scale format
and there's just nothing like that
experience Michaels version of
transformers on IMAX so it's almost
overwhelming just on a visual level we
have these robots that are 35 40 50 feet
tall
well IMAX allows you to give that sense
of scale that you can't create on a lot
of different formats but on IMAX that
allows you to explore the scale even
more the IMAX 3d camera that we used
very extensively goes on all our camera
platforms including the Porsche Cayenne
The Pursuit car which Michael uses a lot
and on the techno crane so that gives
you the ability to have big sweeping
camera moves and fast moves which mike
is obviously well known for
it's a crow I love what Michael does it
in a way where it makes perfect sense
people are really gonna notice the size
and the scope of the movie we've got
some amazing she to this movie and what
I wanted to do with the 3d was dig
really give the audiences a special ride
he's raising the bar for sure